I just remember I liked you and he was
like not now
um I'm married now
um but he was like oh well you can meet
I mean
it's not that way
wait what so he said
it's weird that my celebrity crush is
100 absolutely at Conan O'Brien is that
weird is it
[Applause]
this is the problem here is all of the
is that weird right it is it don't freak
out but guess who it is Conan O'Brien
why am I talking about Ryan Reynolds so
much you have a man crush on Ryan I do
man I don't I feel weird admitting it in
front of you because you're laughing at
me right now but no I'm glad I feel
confidence in might listen I just need
to do this yeah just do that right there
you have come minute right there don't
do that why are you doing that I don't
know because it's more manly I don't
know I'm trying I'm doing my best you're
so old you make dust look like a baby
[Laughter]
trying to process that right
tall yeah you're handsome you have the
perfect amount of scruff and you still
have no Talent
you're gonna say that with a straight
face to
1998's MTV best kiss nominee Ryan
Reynolds
you know I've been meaning to tell you
this for a while but I I probably about
15 years
but uh you know I I feel like I've seen
you all my life
and here you are in person you look so
great would you bite me in the neck oh
my gosh
milia Clark did you get to chat with
everyone backstage
um yeah kind of did you get to talk to
him yeah
Emilia Clarke
[Music]
actually blushing
um yeah I just think you're Wicked
who was my first
celebrity crush
ing a little embarrassing here
all right let's show yours
[Applause]
she's crying
I had a debilitating crush on you in
high school so this is very exciting
that's how I'll take that I mean I had
two huge celebrity crushes it was you
and Macaulay Culkin really
hahaha I love that that's so cool oh
yeah just the two pillars of masculinity
you are pretty cute I just wanna try
that
he's actually gone right now
he was all right yeah he didn't see that
you turned around looking like look he's
just nuggets
I do have one slight request from you
though
um so would you would you be able to ask
me how I'm doing oh bestie
you can say no everyone will hate you
but you can say no no
yes uh well since I you know haven't
been up up to speed on the show thank
you yeah how are you doing
are you still with uh are you still with
John Stamos I know you two have been
going out for a long time that
relationship is it falling apart yet
what's going on why Conan oh I don't
know
oh
[Applause]
Drake I'm also coming for your muscles
so videos and muscles I'm on your ass
Drake
that happened
I've seen Titanic seven and a half times
in theaters he was the love of my life I
had a picture of him in my bedroom that
was signed that I had gotten for my
birthday when I was like 12 years old
and I was walking to Leo and I was like
this is officially the most surreal
moment of my life I could not believe it
I think you probably thinks I'm like a
little weird because whenever I see him
I'm kind of like hey how's it going you
know just in little moments earlier at
the same event or something he's very
sweet though but I I that was truly that
was what was the the craziest experience
was the fact that it was him Michael
come here
oh yeah
we're friends we are friends yeah really
good ones too really really good friends
I know he's really good friends we all
know about his room
all right I'm leaving I'm gone
[Music]
or two seasons of Homeland twice and I'm
freaking out a little bit you've never
met him that is Brody I've never met
birdie before Oh my God okay you want to
meet them now no no no okay no no be
cool
don't stop looking stop it stop doing
that stop stop stop stop it seriously
I'm not good I'm not good no no no stop
it's like it's great
it's like a double interview it's like a
double interview she wants different
show ever oh my God oh my God oh my gosh
yes
amazing my ears are so red in front of
my head that's weird
oh my God oh my God
who is your celebrity crush when you
were younger and have you met himself
yes I had a poster of her on my wallet
if you put up if you find a photo of my
wife around the same age as Olivia
Newton John in like Xanadu or Greece
very similar so careful what you wish
for and I have met her and I told her
and don't ever do that because I told
her okay well he I was a little
overwhelmed I was doing a film with John
Travolta and he said come in hey mate
come in and have some lunch in my
trailer so I went in and a surprise
because I told him Olivia was here so
there is Sandy and Danny from Greece
okay you're way too young I understand
sitting there and I blurted out the
story and she was like
right she totally was looking at me like
this is a stalker this is my worst
nightmare and I was like why the hell
why did I say that so when you meet your
celebrity crush don't tell them okay
that's the key it sounds way less creepy
in your head than when you say it out
loud I know yeah closer than you think
Emilia Clarke Nick Jonas Nick Jonas
Emilia Clarke hi I'm good how are you
you really set me up for failure tonight
what do you call at all why one of your
biggest fans is in the building
you can be a fan I can no I'm a huge fan
I'm like I actually have already met
Amelia and and I said just that where
did you meet at the Oscars after party
yes okay and it wasn't like I'm a fan of
your show actually that was a part of it
but I was like I'm also a fan of your
Instagram which I don't know if it's a
weird thing to say
that's the first time I think I've ever
felt like actual shock we can see it I
hope you got a fan here
we can
so beautiful thank you yeah you're being
really rude
it's good to see you
tonight
oh my God thank you I loved all your
movies
oh really do I look like a new
girlfriend
oh my God
I need a rear view mirror
well I was going to ask you what are you
going to remember about tonight I think
it is